they somehow think they're entitled to
the votes of people who affiliate with
their party rather than the idea that
they actually have to earn them
every election
and the downside of this is that we're
stuck
in a two-party zero-sum binary in our
politics where for one side to win the
other side has to lose
and that creates a really destructive
governing system because there is no
incentive to actually compromise and get
things done as long as that you can
perform and show your base that you're
fighting for them
results aren't actually the thing that
matter and we see that in policy across
the board
[Music]
and now i am pumped to welcome to yang
speaks the head of unite america
an independence independent mr nick
triano but first i want to preface this
by talking about what i'm holding in my
hand which is a hardcover copy of my new
book forward notes on the future of our
democracy it comes out imminently please
grab a copy and i say this because i
know that nick has been working his butt
off for years on a lot of the things
that i write about in this book so it's
appropriate that nick joins us today
thank you for being here nick
my pleasure and thank you for sending me
a manuscript of the book i have it
printed out in pdf version and i tell
you it's hard to put down so i hope
those listen and will do their jobs in
order right away it's a great work
andrew congrats thank you nick you would
think so because a lot of it resembles
your own experience
you know you're like i remember doing
that
so we're going to
regale listeners with
your incredible career path where you
were
the young one of the youngest
congressional candidates in the country
you ran as an independent you got tens
of thousands of votes what led you to do
something
so crazy
as a young person
uh well that's a good question for us
both in throwing our hats in the
electoral ring but
when i was finishing up grad school i
was also running up running a non-profit
in washington called the can kicks back
which was trying to get a bipartisan
solution to the nation's fiscal
challenge
and rather than
pass any legislation to deal with
problems for the next 30 years congress
barely failed
in passing a budget back in 2013 in the
government shutdown and it just became
so clear that the country is going broke
because our political system is broken
and i reached my point of greatest
frustration and said heck if these folks
won't get it done why don't i try and do
something different not only running for
congress as a young person uh but also
outside the two-party system as an
independent well nick
what what a high character thing to do
because
americans were all pissed off when our
government shut down then and we're all
looked up and we're like how the heck is
this happening and i want to dig in a
little bit to that experience of the
government shutting down
because i
looked around me during that time and
thought to myself okay like what is
going wrong given that government
employees are not showing up
and
i know that there were some national
parks that shut down there were some
other things that had problems but part
of me was like it seems like these
people cannot show up to work for a few
days and then nothing really collapses
around us so that there was like there
were there were so many negative
messages from around that time
um the first and most notable being that
if you can't get together to even pass a
budget then how can we have confidence
that you're looking out for the future
yeah
there's there's no looking after the
future it everyone has a plan to win no
one has a plan to actually govern
and that to me
surfaced all the challenges that we see
in our electoral system about the
perverse incentives that exist and i'll
use my congressman at the time as an
example this is why i decided to run for
office i come from pennsylvania we have
gerrymandered districts we have closed
primaries we have very restrictive voter
rules
and so it was a moment of an epiphany
realizing the congressman actually isn't
representing all the voters in the
district he's representing the very few
number of people
who vote in the primary and
that's not what representative democracy
ought to be about
and that's why at the time i thought the
solution was well why can't we have
leaders who aren't representing
political parties or special interests
but actually all the voters and i'll
tell you that message resonated across
the district and across the political
spectrum
in november of 2014 there were people
working the polls on election day green
party libertarian party democrats
republicans independents just because we
may disagree on issues but i think one
thing that unites us is a desire to have
a functioning government one that's even
capable of solving our
challenges and so while on the surface
it looks like we're very divided in our
politics today in many ways we are i
think the one thing that we can agree on
is that government that is supposed to
be of buying for the people no longer is
how old were you when you took on that
run
i was 24 and i turned 25 while
campaigning
wow
so you go back to your hometown in
pennsylvania great state and in many
ways the quintessential battleground
nowadays
i drove through western pa the other day
and i have to say the western part of
the state you'll pass dozens maybe
hundreds of trump signs
and then if you go to to
some of the urban centers then it gets
blue very quickly um but you go back
there as a 24 year old that must have
been a very tough sell in terms of
saying hey the the whipper snapper is
back to run for congress what was your
experience like and how did you get
started
i thought it'd be a tough sell but when
i said that i was running without a
party and i wasn't accepting special
interest contributions i didn't need to
explain
much more to people to earn their
support and we ultimately ended up with
about 13 of the vote far from what we
needed but by orders of magnitude
greater than many other independent
candidates you've run
for office because we bootstrapped it
like you did in your campaign uh
and
however it also revealed to me the
structural barriers that exist in trying
to inject new competition into the
system
how to collect two and a half times more
signatures to get on the ballot right
had to explain to media why they
shouldn't bother covering our campaign
uh had to think about how to raise money
from individuals at 100 200 at a time
and not getting five thousand dollar
checks from pacs because of the
committees i sat on in congress so
it was also a first-hand learning
experience for me as to the barriers of
why we seem to be stuck with the lesser
of two evils in our country and
that's my mission in the time since is
is how do we level the playing field how
do we fix the system
have you gotten to the chapter in my
book about running for congress
uh i have gotten to the chapter on
running for office generally yeah well
there's one where i try and
illustrate all the structural
impediments uh in running for office uh
particularly as a first time candidate
and i know you ran into them firsthand
so now you're a 25 year old
former congressional candidate
uh what's your next move i mean you had
first-hand experience uh with what the
institutions
um
were and weren't doing and your story
reminds me a little bit of crystal ball
do you know crystal
mm-hmm
uh so crystal didn't run as an
independent she was ran as a as kind of
an anti-establishment dem
um in a very very red district if i
recall um but i i find that people who
run for congress have a much
more developed perspective of the
process and it's something that i
love about your background and some of
the other former candidates background
it makes you
understand things much more viscerally
but what did you pivot to next because
at that point you have a very
interesting story but uh in my mind it
would be unclear how you go from
candidate to reformer my next move was
in in the course of doing this i met a
college professor named charlie whelan
at dartmouth wrote a book called the
centrist manifesto
and his vision was to create a third
force in our politics that could elect a
sufficient number of leaders to the u.s
senate where they can actually control
the balance of power
and hopefully force the institution back
to some problem solving i was inspired
by that vision i joined our board and
within two years
decided to come on board
replace our outgoing executive director
at the time and
and try and bring this vision to life
and and my
pitch to do that was to try and do that
at the state level to actually recruit
and support a slate of independent
candidates and build real infrastructure
uh for them
because i saw the missing infrastructure
when i ran
but it wasn't long before we reached the
end of the 2018 election cycle when
those candidates and others had lost
that we concluded
there weren't just large structural
challenges facing new competition but
also large psychological challenges too
with how tribal our politics have
become and the lack of an identity for
a third force so we went back to the
drawing board and eventually decided to
focus on
reforms to our political system that
would not only level the playing field
but also improve the governing
incentives for both major parties as
well
[Music]
[Applause]
do you love coffee because if you do
we've got a new sponsor alert this
episode of yank speaks is brought to you
by trade coffee
so when you're if you're the type person
that goes to bed thinking about your
next cup of coffee or you're a crazy
coffee nut or you're just a casual
coffee drinker trades goals make every
cup of coffee your best if ever and it's
a coffee subscription service so
basically you go to their website you
take their coffee quiz or like the
french press or the automatic drip or a
cold brew whatever it is you get the
answer and trades will pair you with the
perfect coffee to fit your taste they'll
match your coffees you love from over
400 craft coffees and send you a freshly
roasted bag as often as you like i
guarantee you'll love your first match
and then replace it with your first your
first bag or replace it with a different
bag for free if you don't like it so
you can try this and you can give
feedback as you sip so if you like
certain things and don't like others you
can improve what's coming to your door
so right now for our listeners trade is
offering you your first bag free at
checkout so to get yours go to
drinktrade.com yang use the promo code
yang take the quiz start your journey to
the perfect cup of coffees that's
drinktrade.com
yang use the promo code yang to order
your first bag of coffee free from trade
enjoy it
[Music]
[Applause]
so these are things that you learned the
hard way it sounds like over the last
six or seven years uh and tell
the listeners what the heck is unite
america
uh no i mean aren't we already united i
mean it's obviously a dumb question it's
easier we're just talking about
polarization um but you say you joined
the board and then you became the head
of it uh this is
an organization that's promoting
independent candidates and centrist
ideas and uh process changes
that's where our roots have been in the
independent
world but i'll be clear that we have
pivoted from that as an organization and
i have two in my own journey in
political reform which is to say that no
matter if you think we ought to have
many parties or just two let's at least
have some that can govern and so
creating a more functional and
representative government is the mission
of united america and the means of
getting there is through nonpartisan
electoral reforms that can empower
voters with more voice and more choice
in elections so that it is they who are
deciding the outcomes and not narrow
groups of more partisan voters and
primaries or special interests that try
to influence the process
so
success to us looks like a government
that's capable of solving the biggest
challenges facing
our country
and we're well in our way of trying to
get there by changing the incentive
structure of our politics today through
these reforms
well the biggest changes that we need
i think you and i agree on this are open
primaries and ranked choice voting and
they kind of go hand in hand because of
what you just said
so you describe the spoiler effect and
i've heard a lot of this even though
it's been rumored that i'm starting a
third party and so all of a sudden
immediately people are like oh you're
going to empower the bad guys and the
bad guys uh in in this discussion
typically are the republicans at least
among you know democrats and so it's
like oh third party intrinsically bad
because uh you're going to help the
other side win
um and so you need something to remove
the spoiler effect and it's interesting
how
conditioned voters are around the
spoiler effect uh it it i feel like
somehow somewhere along the lines uh the
democratic party or the parties
generally have just incepted everyone
that it's like ooh other party
they somehow think they're entitled to
the votes of people who affiliate with
their party rather than the idea that
they actually have to earn them
every election
and the downside of this is that we're
stuck in a two-party zero-sum binary in
our politics where for one side to win
the other side has to lose
and that creates a really destructive
governing system because there is no
incentive to actually compromise and get
things done as long as that you can
perform and show your base that you're
fighting for them uh results aren't
actually the thing that matter and we
see that in policy across the board if
our political system actually rewarded
problem solving we still wouldn't be
talking about immigration as an issue or
we still wouldn't be talking about what
we do about climate we still wouldn't
have a 21 trillion dollar debt so that's
the consequence of being stuck in a
dysfunctional two-party system doesn't
necessarily mean a two-party system
can't work in fact we've had one that
did for a long time but it's very
difficult for it to work where we are
today in our politics with how sordid
the parties are and how the primary
process
gives a disproportionate influence to
the most extreme voters
i think that's a very key
takeaway for everyone which is that
results now have no correlation to your
electoral success
and you can see that in the fact that
the us is now ranked 28th in basic
measurements like
clean air and clean water education
our life expectancy is lower than that
of other developed countries like really
basic stuff
and you would think that if things were
going badly then you would vote the
bombs out of office whoever the bums
happen to be
but now the facts on the ground don't
really correspond to whether or not you
get voted back in congress has an
approval rating of 26
and individual members have a
re-election rate of 94
in part because of the distorted party
primary system that you're you're
describing
and i was blown away nick when i ran for
president around the fact when i talked
facts around for example
eliminating 4 million manufacturing jobs
over the last number of years it just
went in one ear and out the other
for
political figures media it's like that
that reality does not matter except in
so far as it intercepts with what's
going on in the
media
cycle of the day
or
uh something that's going to inflame
uh a particular group on social media
like
does facts have left the building and it
makes me super sad uh you know one of
the major challenges trying to get facts
back into the building um but you can
tell politicians are unfortunately now
very quickly conditioned not to respond
on facts there was their condition to
respond on communications
yeah and i think that's the overwhelming
dynamic of our elections especially in
general elections is you don't actually
have to earn
more than 50 support as much as you have
to just convince voters how unpalatable
the other candidate is right so
democrats say if republicans get into
office they're going to take away your
health care republicans they have
democrats into get into office they're
going to take away your guns and so just
this is a feedback loop that cycle over
cycle is what is helping to drive the
polarization it is not serving the
voters well but to your point it
definitely serves the politicians well
90 of them are getting re-elected
by the way it serves the interest groups
that are raising money it serves the
media that is also earning money off of
our clicks and eyeballs so division has
become the business model of politics
today in part because there's so little
competition in the system outside of
just one democrat one republican in most
general elections
one thing my wife evelyn found
fascinating is that our founding fathers
were not fans of political parties and
this duopoly we are living that everyone
takes for granted it's like of course
there should be two major parties but
this situation is one of the nightmarish
worst case scenarios for the founding
fathers like if you told them hey there
are two parties that control everything
they would have been like this is
exactly what we were trying to prevent
yep i think adam said it was the
greatest political evil he dreaded under
our constitution washington warned of it
in his farewell
and so if you're an alien descending to
america and you read our declaration you
read our constitution you will not find
a mention of political parties in there
you'll find
three branches or separation of powers
or bill of rights the party system and
how we do elections is not in there we
created it after the fact and i think
that's important for two reasons the
first is that uh it doesn't have to be
this way it does not have to be this way
and the second is we can change it
because the same you can change it let's
preach nick
this constitution says it is the time
place and manner of our elections is up
to the states if not for some act of
congress and so the movement that i
think we're seeing develop and that we
need to fuel
is this idea that we can change our
electoral system state by state or
through congress so that our
government's actually responsive to the
people
and that's that not only is happening
now there's historical precedent for
that you go back a hundred years
right there was no secret ballot state
legislatures were electing senators
women didn't have the right to vote
corporations were giving directly to
candidates those things changed because
people who didn't agree with each other
on policy join together to say the
system isn't working for any of us let's
change it and if they can do that at the
turn of the 20th century i think we can
do it today with all the organizing
power
that we have and that's the task before
us that is the task before us my friend
we're gonna do it you've been leading
this charge for years i am now going to
be joining you it's welcome yeah it's
the right way
uh it's the right struggle uh we're
going to
raise a movement an army
now
when i was talking to evelyn about this
i said look uh the democratic party
didn't exist when the constitution was
written it came into being a little
while later it was called the democratic
republicans which i thought was
interesting for people and then the
republicans
were originally an anti-slave northern
party which i think now people would
would find somewhat surprising that came
into existence decades later uh so and
there were other parties uh at different
points
before the gop came into existence and
so
right now this two-party duopoly that
we've been living with for quite some
time
really is just an invention
and it's an invention that made more
sense pre-technology
where they were this filtration system
but now
we don't need it as much
you should be able to reach people in
different ways that you don't
necessarily need just to have the d or
the r but the the parties have made it
so that politics has become much more
about tribes than about policy and this
is something that a lot of of americans
because they're
into our armed media
don't understand which is that
if you sit
a conservative down uh and say hey do
you think drug prices are too high
they'll say yes and say like do you want
to stick it to the drug companies and
get those prices down they'll say
they'll say yes
and obviously you know you get someone
on on the left uh you'd probably get the
the same
policy stance
so
why is it that these two people seem to
regard each other as like their worst
enemies so one of the misconceptions
that people have
is that voters are voting on policy but
the truth is at this point they're
voting on tribes
and to your point nick what we need is a
new tribe that people can subscribe to
around these principles of making our
government functional for us and saying
that there's no
reason
why we need to have party primaries then
make it such that 83 percent of
americans are disenfranchised in
congressional races and i think it was
your organization unite america that
came out with a staggering statistic
that
83 of races were decided by was it 10 of
voters
yep
uh we released a report a few months ago
called the primary problem and it looked
at the 2020 election
which we celebrate as high voter turnout
67 in the general election but what most
folks don't realize is that by the
general election 83 of congressional
seats were already effectively decided
in the primary because they're
overwhelmingly democrat or they're
overwhelmingly republican so whoever the
party's nominee is is almost guaranteed
to win and then when we looked at well
how many americans actually voted in
those primaries that had any kind of
choice
the answer was just 10
and so you have a very small number of
americans who are disproportionately
on the extremes of both parties deciding
the vast majority of electoral outcomes
and not only does that disenfranchise
millions of americans from real choice
it is distorting our representation it
is fueling division in our politics so
if we want to fix our politics we have
to fix this primary problem it's the
biggest solvable challenge that we face
in our democracy today
[Music]
[Applause]
real talk folks how's your mental health
i just had my therapy session with
better help today and they are our
sponsor on yang speaks and what
better help is it's not
quote-unquote therapy or self-help it is
just
personalized
counseling done securely online it's
super easy it's professional it's secure
uh you can message your therapist at any
time it's fantastic so whether you're
talking about depression or stress or
anxiety or relationships or trouble
sleep being for me
it's about figuring out what i want to
do next every day put one from the other
releasing some steam and thinking about
the goals i want to accomplish in life
and how i get there you can use better
help for everything i have friends that
use it i literally preach this thing to
everybody that can get
within earshot of me and i know yang
does it too
you need to prioritize your mental
health and better help is the place to
go and they're our sponsor and right now
we want you to start living living a
happier life today so as a listener
you're going to get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yanks it's not a crisis line it's
convenient it's professional affordable
anything you share is confidential so
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp help.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
let's fix the primary problem uh we're
gonna go after it now one thing i'm
genuinely curious about nick because
you've been in this space for a while
how would you describe the tribe of
people that are into
reforming the primary process uh and our
democracy
if you were to draw someone up i'm going
to describe you for just a moment
because we we know you a little bit so
you're like a young upstanding
[Laughter]
professional who lives in
colorado which is a purple state very
fitting
and
you all get together large groups of
people periodically what does that crowd
look like like who is
in the movement now
i i think it's a diverse cross-section
of americans you have people on the
right who want to drain the swamp you
have people on the left who are upset
about the corruption of money in
politics
it is it cuts across ideology you know
some of these ideas like hey should
everyone have a say in a primary not
just the party the dominican district or
shouldn't elections be decided by a
majority of voters
90
of americans can agree on it the
challenge that we face is that
we're surrounded by
a media system a political system that
keeps us divided for their own benefit
now if we were to say hey now instead of
dividing us for your benefit we're going
to unite for hours to actually try and
fix the system that's the tipping point
that i think that a movement can reach
to really be successful long term and it
takes the idea of people being willing
to put country over party to realize
that it's not the next election that is
the most necessary the most important
thing we can possibly
uh be organizing around it is what is
this democracy going to look like over
the next century if we can't get it to
be more functional than it is uh right
now and so i think we have to lay down
our partisan arms at least in this
context join with each other and pursue
common sense ideas that will put voters
first
i love the sound of that nick
and
one of the things that i'm excited to do
is get to work on the state level so
what are some of the states
that
have a lot of energy around reforming
the primary process so that it becomes
open primaries and ranked choice voting
yeah so when we look at a policy suite
that can address the problem we're
looking at how do you end partisan
gerrymandering so primaries aren't the
only elections that matter how do we
expand the use of vote by mail in a
secure way which is shown to increase
turnout and informed turnout among
people how do we advance ranked choice
voting so that winners of elections
represent a broad cross-section of
voters have to and how do we replace
party primaries with nonpartisan
primaries so that there's one ballot all
candidates run all voters run those are
the four
reforms that unite america is pursuing
and there's great momentum
in the last election cycle
at the ballot
voters adopted an independent
redistricting commission in virginia in
alaska as you know voters adopted the
first final four voting system which is
a top four nonpartisan primary with
ranked choice in the general election
and it's not just happening at the
ballot in this past legislative session
this year colorado and utah on a
bipartisan basis voted to expand the use
of ranked choice voting at a local level
23 cities in utah will be using it this
fall
and we also saw vermont on a bipartisan
basis adopt vote by mail in their
election so in different states this is
taking a bit of a different form but
together we see a rising movement of
reformers who are trying to get an
electoral system that can better
represent
the people and more states need to
follow and that's where the yang gang
and others can
pitch in and get involved we've been so
grateful at america to be able to
mobilize resources to
citizen founded citizen-led campaigns in
states where a group of activists have
come together imagined something better
and put together a campaign that got it
done
we can do it
we can do it and alaska's success
redounded nationally when senator lisa
murkowski was one of the few republicans
to criticize trump which is political
suicide for most republicans her
approval rating in alaska among
republicans plummeted something like 15
or 20 percent uh now
alaska last year adopted an open primary
so lisa does not have to go through
a primary process which i'm going to
suggest might have
freed her to speak her mind where trump
was concerned and one of the arguments
i'm making to everyone is that if you
change this process where people don't
have to go through the
party primary you're going to see a lot
of
legislators all of a sudden become much
more independent and rational
getting rid of the party primaries can
liberate our leaders to actually lead
and that is on the democratic side
that's the republican side and that is
leveling the playing field for new
competition as well
when we look at some of the most extreme
folks you've gotten elected marjorie
taylor greene madison cawthron out of
the republican party last election cycle
you run the numbers only about five
percent to eight percent of the voters
in their district actually cast ballots
for them in the deciding election in
their district wow and so we have to
shift the number of people who are
actually dictating these electoral
outcomes because if we make it more
representative we're going to get not
only better leaders but those leaders
are going to be incentivized to
represent a broader swath of their
electorate and finally be able to say i
can take this tough vote i can reach
across the aisle i can speak my mind
because it's not going to be five
percent of voters in the district
determining my re-election i represent
all the people and i think for senator
murkowski uh going going back
she lost a primary in 2010 to a tea
party challenger but the voters in
alaska organized to write her name in on
the ballot successfully in the general
election the first time that's been done
for u.s senate in half a century and as
you hear her tell it that was the moment
where she viewed her reelection as uh
being able to
represent this eclectic group of
alaskans who returned her to office no
longer was it the fact that she owed her
election to just one party's primary
voters and so imagine if we had a senate
where we had a dozen two dozen more
leaders knowing that they don't just
represent the five to ten percent of
americans who uh are on the extremes of
both sides
that is the vision that we're gonna make
real nick and if there is someone who
should get behind this i'm gonna just
describe this for a moment
it's a democrat in a red state where you
know that your
candidate has no chance uh you know
you're going to be noble and put up a
good fight but you're going to lose or a
republican in a blue state like a place
like new york where i am where you also
are in the minority and your vote never
matters there's a party primary on it on
the other side and you're just finding
out who the heck they're going to run
and then after it it makes it to the
general then you know your person's
going lose you should be ticked off
like people are getting
locked out of the election system by
these party primaries where
by the time it gets to you it's already
been decided what kind of democracy is
that and it's up to the states to change
it if enough of us get together we can
change it everywhere
and actually make it so that everyone
gets to participate
yeah and that's what it's about
this isn't about some
desire for
moderation necessarily in our politics
or splitting the difference between both
sides it's just making it work it's
better about better
participation more competition and when
you have more participation more
competition you're going to get better
representation and my feeling is if this
country is better represented we're also
going to get better results to the
challenges that we care about this is
small d democracy and it's
important that voters across the
spectrum
join together to bring about uh these
changes we have the means and levers to
do so one of the things that united
america is focused on is it's also going
to take resources
and in the last election there's only
about 36 million dollars invested in any
reform campaign that was on the ballot
in in the country in the entire country
36 million dollars crazy
how much is spent on
uh
one side or the other trying to win
six billion fourteen billion dollars was
spent last election cycle by both
parties for uh for federal office
so
think about that everyone listening to
this 14 billion on one side of the other
winning a lot of that's going to cancel
itself out
and then only 36 million on the
fundamental problems which are pissing
us all off
yep and and so
the case to donors small donors large
donors is instead of only fueling the
problem where does most of that money go
as you know andrew 30 second ads
convincing half the country about the
other side being such a thing i do like
my ads nick no i'm kidding
your ads are good uh let's invest the
money where we can fix that was the
problem nick
more millions of dollars into more ads
with this face on it
no i you know i'd be very happy for all
that money to go to actually solve the
plumbing problems uh so
again you know and
um one phenomena that i complain about
is that
according to the numbers to raise money
from someone uh you have to alarm them
so we we get all these alarmist emails
where every day the house is burning
down
[Laughter]
and it's making everyone crazy
yeah well here's where our alarm is and
this is not and ought not to be
a partisan issue january 6
january 6 was the 9 11 for our
democracy if there's anything that's
sacred in our democracy it's the
peaceful transfer of power and it was
attacked that day
and it's sad to me that it seems some
parts of our politics and people in it
have sort of moved on
how do we move on after witnessing an
insurrection at our capital
now go back a few hours before the
attack happened and you have former
president trump stand on the national
mall and said that we're here to get our
people to fight and if they don't fight
we're going to primary them
we're going to primary them
and so again the primary problem
surfaces as he's using as a cuddle to
beat
legislators into submission so january 6
is our clarion call to remove the
primaries from the system not just
because we care about solving you name
your issue but because we care about
actually trying to save our democracy
if we continue in this doom loop as some
have called it of polarization
and winning is the only thing that
matters then our governing institutions
and our elections themselves become
just
part of the political game and
we're soon approaching a place in our
politics where
few people will accept the results of
our elections either because it's voter
fraud on one side or voter suppression
um
on the other we can't let that happen we
have to hold something sacred in our
democracy and our election system is
certainly uh one of them
[Music]
[Applause]
sports have long been an important and
defining part of our history
with their impact and influence
key moments in sports have helped shape
heal
and inspire it has been said that i have
two alternatives
either go to jail
or go to the army
but i would like to say that there is
another alternative
that alternative is justice
i'm doc rivers and i'm proud to present
a new podcast documentary series called
it was said sports where i guide you
through six of the most impactful and
timeless speeches in sports history the
question has already been answered
should we be here
yes
listen and follow it was said sports a
documentary podcast presentation of
shining city audio a c13 originals and
john meacham studio
available now wherever you listen to
your podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
i've got a vision to pitch you on nick
that i'm sure you've thought a lot about
so this is my phone i i manage a lot of
my life on it i transfer
information uh and money in different
ways
and
one thing i hear all the time is why
can't people vote on their phone
and i feel like there are two major
impediments number one is technological
where people are concerned that it would
be hacked or fail in some way
or
people
would somehow find out about how
everyone voted
uh and then the other is the nature of
the party primary process that we've
been talking about which is that uh if
you're a party and if you look into this
no one on either side has embraced
mobile voting
even though you would think that at
least one party might think well this
might help me because more people will
vote
but neither party has been into it and
they've pled all the time that the
tech's not ready for prime time but the
technology is getting better and you'd
have to say at some point it will be
ready for prime time i have friends who
are working on it and insist that
it's at least pilot ready now uh there
are folks in the blockchain community
who say look um in principle we should
be able to do this pretty
straightforwardly because if you tamper
with anything in the blockchain
obviously you know it's immediately
evident uh so one of the visions i'd
like to pitch
americans on is
we should be able to vote on our mobile
phones there should not be this
ridiculous stand in line at our local
gymnasium
and have it be that people are somehow
disenfranchised and locked out and i'll
say too
i ran for
mayor and i can't tell you how many
people came up to me and said hey i want
to vote for you but i needed to register
as a democrat
four months ago and did not do so so now
i can't vote for you i mean that's
another and you know you'd think like
the democrats would be like oh you know
we're all about everyone voting it's
like well you're not into anyone who's
not a registered democrat four months
ago
voting
but
to the primary message around mobile
voting
shouldn't we be able to vote on our
phones the same way we manage the rest
of our lives
i think the point that you're driving
which i agree with is our entire
election system is outdated and now is
the time to be thinking about how do we
move into the 21st century even when you
consider why do we vote on tuesdays that
goes back to the 19th century when we
needed to allow enough people
time to get from wherever it was where
they were farming to the county seat to
vote and back again by market day i mean
we we take certain things for granted
because it's always been that way but
there ought to be and there are better
ways of doing it and i think when it
comes to mobile voting there are pilots
happening and that even includes for
overseas and military voters that some
states are starting to experience that's
the only one that that's gotten approved
because right overseas military
everyone's like well that makes sense
that that's the only way they could vote
right but i i think one thing that we
have to do is uh ensure that we maintain
trust in the system both in reality and
perception and right now as you know we
have a crisis of confidence just in the
way that our current election system is
held in part because of how polarized
these issues are becoming now there are
some states that are doing it right
kentucky among them where there has been
bipartisan support
for increasing voting access such as
number of days for early voting as well
as for increasing voter security such as
being able to verify identity on a male
ballot through signature through
government id
and these things aren't mutually
exclusive we can have a more accessible
and more secure system but unfortunately
our politicians are now using this issue
as another wedge issue to mobilize their
base again because of the way that their
primary system works democracies become
in the crosshairs
so are you right now optimistic
pessimistic some combination because you
talked about how the movement's been
growing and i want to grow the movement
very very significantly i think that
there's no other way out
uh you know i looked at the map in the
math
and
it seems to me that
uh so there are people out there who
think well the democrats have
demographics on their side because the
country is going to be
growing more diverse and so eventually
democrats will win out and if you have
that as your belief then i've got a
couple of data points for you
number one is that last year
democrats lost 13
house seats when they thought they were
gonna win five to ten and so
demographics and theory should have been
helping because
you know time had passed
um but the other thing is is the way our
uh electoral college
and
map work out
um you're going to see
people in less populated states be
consistently overrepresented
and that's not going to change so if you
have a diversifying population
that doesn't help you do anything other
than run up the score in certain states
unless those people were to move in mass
to
wyoming and north dakota and a bunch of
other places
which they're not going to do
so
what you see
ahead by the numbers is polarization
going up and up because all the
incentives are around polarization going
going up and you see two sides that are
going to be gridlocked and deadlocked
and
unable to get much done um it's going to
get worse and worse
there is no path back that doesn't
involve some sort of systemic reform
like what we're describing that changes
the incentives makes it so that you
actually get rewarded for being
reasonable you get rewarded for being
human you get rewarded for being
independent and you don't live in fear
of the 17 most extreme voters in your
district uh and then have by the way
leaders who can then use that 17 to beat
you over the head if you
uh say anything that they disagree
with yeah i i think reform is thrown
around as a term by people of different
ideas of what it means
to me it means how do we reform the
system so that we're better capable of
bridging our differences to get to
better outcomes in the public interest
reform isn't how do we manipulate the
system to make it easier for a narrow
majority to bludgeon the other side into
submission because my fear of that
approach is that it will only accelerate
our division
and we are staring at the prospects of
actual political violence if that trend
continues
100 we're already seeing it so if we
want to accelerate that trend that's the
direction you go if we want to actually
turn down the temperature and get to a
system that can represent a large
multi-racial diverse society that we
have we need a political system that can
give better representation to more
groups of people and actually kind of
incentivize coalition building and
problem solving and that's what this set
of nonpartisan reforms that i've been
talking about can help lead us to and by
the way the reforms that i've mentioned
sit at what is the nexus of what is
possible to achieve right now and can be
impactful hopefully that overton window
shifts over time and we can be talking
about more ambitious reforms uh down the
road so this is a movement that will and
needs to continue to build and to your
question i am optimistic about it you
know right after my campaign andrew you
asked me before
i i thought i would try and find support
to champion these reforms in
pennsylvania and there was no one
interested in it no one funding it no
one wanted to be part of it and so
i wound up going in a different route
today
it's different we we are we and
represent us have uh created an
accelerator award where people can start
a campaign and apply for funding and
support we had more applications than we
knew what to do with when we opened it
up because people are joining this
movement and it needs to be leader full
there isn't about one person one
ideology we need many people getting
involved and leading these campaigns at
a local state and national level and i'm
seeing that more now than in any time
over the past
decade one of the things i hope for nick
is that we can make this movement
positive optimistic solutions oriented
even fun because i think right now most
people are really tuned down on politics
for a decent reason because it's
exhausting
it's depressing
it just makes you more angry and
frustrated
and there's a real need i think for
uplift
i mean the world is not doing well the
country's not doing well our democracy
is not doing well um but
all of that said
it's going to take a lot of people
coming together to change it and i think
that that can be fueled by anger and
frustration yes that there's some of
that but hopefully it can also be fueled
by
hope and
optimism and positivity and universality
and that's what i
want to inject into it i i want to build
a really exciting movement and this is
one of the problems we have is that if i
run around you know i'm actually going
to say too um i became
well known for running on a thousand
bucks a month for everyone and that's
something that most everyone can
understand um if you say hey open
primaries some people understand it and
some other people are like you know um
so what one of the challenges we have is
to try and make this translatable
and
relatable and relatable to people
one of the arguments i'm going to make
is that if you want something like
universal basic income it's going to be
much more likely to have it happen
if representatives in the government are
actually responsive to the people as
opposed to narrow subsections of people
and very special interests
yeah i would go one further andrew and
say if we want our great american
experiment of self-government and the
longest living constitution in the world
to endure we're going to need to make
some serious changes to our politics and
it doesn't need to be doom and gloom to
your point there's something special
that
we don't need permission from the
political establishment we don't need
permission from the parties to actually
go out and do this it'll take people
running for office and getting elected
on this platform and it will also take
in half the states that have it us
utilizing our direct citizen initiative
processes too
that's part of the secret sauce that has
led america to be resilient over
now close to 250 years which is that we
don't have a perfect system
but we have the tools to make it more
perfect over time
and i'll tell you when i ran for office
as a 25 year old against a system that
looked like it was intractable and
immovable
going out to collect 7 500 signatures
from fellow citizens in my community and
then sharing the debate stage with a
sitting u.s congressman was an
empowering experience
for me
and getting involved and so i think for
all the reasons why we think the system
is stacked against us let's realize who
actually has the power
uh and the moment that we do as of the
american people i think we will overcome
you know nick i had such a similar
experience on the presidential trail
[Music]
like the you well you know just you know
i was on the debate stage seven times
with joe and bernie and camel and
everyone else so you're like hey
you know and i i was just a guy
[Laughter]
so hopefully we can build on that uh
thrilled to be your companion in this
movement we're gonna do something really
amazing and profound you know why
because it needs to be done
and as long as we can actually
show it to enough americans they'll be
like oh yeah that's totally what we need
to do uh and that's my job that's your
job hopefully that's the job of everyone
who's listening to this or watching this
today
nick love your new book it's called
forward notes in our democracy uh the
future of our democracy by nick triano
well i have joking because i seriously
think that nick could have written this
book uh and
we would have had a lot of the same
takeaways and substance uh unite america
indeed man we have a lot of work to do
but i'm inspired to be joining you your
organization's great your community is
great and we're gonna grow it like mad
uh andrew thank you for your leadership
thank you for taking on this next
challenge together and thank you for the
yang gang that's out there that knows
there's something better in our politics
we don't have to stick with the status
quo so i'm excited to work
with you on this important endeavor who
likes the status quo i mean that's one
of the things that just blows my mind
when people are like yeah you're like
you really think things are going
like who's into
what's going on right now like nobody so
you know it's like hey we're gonna do
something different be like oh thank god
thank god that they're going down a
different inclusive
road that everyone can join
indeed thank you
[Music]
you